to Long crime daily we end our show with
new developments in Wisconsin a federal
judge ruled that a wrongful death
lawsuit against Kyle rinthouse can move
forward renhouse stood trial in November
of 2021 for killing two people and
wounding a third during civil unrest in
Kenosha the jury acquitted karenhouse
who was just 17 at the time he opened
fire with an AR-15 that same year John
Huber filed a wrongful death lawsuit
against Rittenhouse City officials and
members of law enforcement his son 26
year old Anthony Huber was killed while
attempting to disarm Rittenhouse with a
skateboard Huber claims officers allowed
the dangerous situation to unfold
violating his son's constitutional
rights and resulting in his death he
also believes Rittenhouse conspired with
law enforcement to intentionally harm
protesters
Huber is seeking unspecified damages
during trial writtenhouse was questioned
about the circumstances around Huber's
death here's what he had to say
as I'm running past
Mr Huber he's holding escape with like a
baseball bat and he swings it down and I
block it with my arm trying to prevent
it from hitting me but it still hits me
in the neck I get light-headed I almost
pass out and I Stumble and hit the
ground Mr Huber
immediately after I'm kicked in the face
runs up as I'm sitting up he strikes me
in the neck with his skateboard a second
time then what happened
he grabs my gun and I can feel it
pulling away from me and this I can feel
the strap starting to come off my my
body
and what do you do then I fire one shot
when you shoot him he's got his
skateboard in his hand yes you didn't
see any gun in his hand correct no you
didn't see a knife no you didn't see a
bat no you didn't see a club no all he's
got is the skateboard right that he's
hit me in the head with twice yes okay
and you intended to pull the trigger at
that moment with your AR-15 correct yes
the end of that gun was pointed directly
at his chest when you pulled the trigger
correct yes and you knew that correct
yes and you still pulled the trigger
didn't you yes
Bernard renhouse won the criminal case
does that mean he'll likely Prevail in a
wrongful death lawsuit as well
not at all Brian because you got to
think when it comes to civil lawsuit the
burden is completely different at the
time of trial of a criminal trial the
burden was beyond A Reasonable Doubt and
the prosecution had to disprove that he
didn't act in self-defense when it comes
to a civil lawsuit the burden is more
likely than not preponderance of the
evidence 51 against 49 and you're
dealing with uh the same jury pool but
we also got to take into account that
caliber in-house testified and his
testimony at the criminal trial will be
used at the time of this Civil Trial so
we'll just have to wait and see but he
has more much more hurdles to jump over
in terms of the Civil Trial all right
Terry do you think we'll see similar
lawsuits by others who are killed and
injured yeah I think we could see
similar lawsuits we know that at least
one other person was killed one other
person was injured I think here for a
wrongful death action though what
they're going to have to establish is
there was some sort of Reckless or
negligent act that it caused it's that
causal connection it caused the death of
the individual and the fact that they
are related to the individual which they
already have if they bring a wrongful
death action so I think as against you
know Kyle Rittenhouse I mean I think
they're going to be able to prove that
there is that causal connection but we
know that the lawsuit also sued the city
and other officials in that instance I
think it might be a little bit difficult
to have that causal connection but you
know if you sue called Rittenhouse
there's no Deep Pockets so I am certain
that the family established this lawsuit
because they wanted to get some sort of
civil you know money in this event and
it obviously is not going to bring back
their son or you know their brother or
whatever the relationship is but it is
going to make it a little bit easier for
them to move on and it gives them
compensation for whatever the rest of
his life might have given them and so I
think that's why they decided to also
Sue these other entities but it might be
very difficult under these circumstances
because what kind of Duty did they have
how would they have known that this was
going to occur yeah I'm interested in
that connection as well and how the
self-defense applies and so hey I'm a
criminal attorney so we'll see how it
plays out well thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on lawn crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
[Music]
foreign